my Olympic coach told me after a
particularly challenging workout where I
could not hit my splits before going to
the Rio Olympics that that was okay it
was the rule of thirds and he was an
Olympian so I was I always soaked in
everything he said and I was like what's
the rule of thirds and he said when
you're chasing a dream or doing anything
hard you're meant to feel good a third
of the time okay a third of the time and
crappy a third of the time and if the
ratio is roughly in that range then
you're doing fine so today was the
crappy day along your dream chasing and
if the ratio is off like you feel too
good all the time or too bad then you
you've got to look at if you're
fatiguing or or not trying hard enough
or pushing yourself